en París el transporte sigue muy
perturbado
la basura sigue amontonándose y los
conductores preocupados por una posible
nueva escasez de combustible Ya que en
efecto se ha reanudado la huelga en la
refinerías Si conduces todos los días
unas 40 veces al día te asustas bastante
puertos bloqueados terminales de gnl
paralizadas la intersindical permanece
unida y pide ser recibida urgentemente
por Emanuel macón para que retire su
reforma pero el presidente sigue
delegando en el portavoz del gobierno
la puerta del gobierno si ese es su
pregunta está siempre abierta con el
diálogo y a través del diálogo se han
logrado avances para los franceses
en el senado el debate ha terminado de
forma concluyente la derecha ha
conseguido aprobar el artículo 7
decisivo para aumentar la edad de
jubilación las tensiones son palpables
incluso entre los macronistas dividido
sobre la reforma ahora el gobierno podrá
aprobar el texto sin recurrir al
artículo
49.3 de la Constitución Gracias al apoyo
de la derecha
lucena adopté el artículo indignados los
sindicatos han prometido dar respuesta
con dos días más de huelga general el
próximo sábado y el día en el que el
senado y la asamblea disputan sobre la
ley muy probablemente el 15 de marzo